[Music]
let's talk about
sex yes sir yes sir
oh never mind okay what is sexy here uh
physical
attractiveness bias oh bias
bias yes such as like do attractive
people
get the jobs do attractive people yeah
better stuff
whereas less attractive people lose out
on a lot of suggestions
completely attractiveness privileges oh
yeah how many opportunities i lost
you no yeah no
i don't see it all right so i don't
judge by race i judge by ugly
not true and that is the case that this
article is making
uh and they're putting the whole
attractiveness bias thing
to the test within the criminal justice
world
we know about that one dude that got a
modeling career
yeah yeah exactly and did he get a
sentencing
no the judge fell in love and just set
him free yeah oh you watch
what's his name jeremy i forgot his name
but he's marrying like a
chick like a like a loaded that guy's
pretty fine though
yeah he's a good looking you can't even
hate on it bro he that [ __ ] has
cheekbones for days
yeah it's like a skeleton with skin he's
a stud
do you guys feel that way when you meet
someone that's attractive versus
unattractive and i'm not saying this is
intentional obviously this is obviously
a very unintentional it's very
interesting
do you feel like attractive people are
are like like
uh good people inherently and you kind
of give them the benefit of that
i feel like you probably get everything
you want so i got to be two times harder
on you
oh interesting so you go the you're
intentionally going up there next to me
i go okay that's cool yeah yeah yeah
okay i'll take it back that's true
i'll be like i have my guards up you
know you can't you can't have one over
on me
and you're like but you're so nice okay
see that's the thing that always
surprises me when really attractive
people
are really nice and genuine people i'm
like what
you can't have everything because
usually attractive people are [ __ ]
it's tough though because you don't know
if that's just what they put on that
that may not be their true
maybe they're tired of everyone trying
to [ __ ] them all day maybe
maybe maybe that's why they're so mad
yeah they're just like stop stop trying
to [ __ ]
meet yeah you know me that's how josh
lives josh liver that's not josh
he's an attractive person yeah he's nice
but he yeah he's everybody wants to [ __ ]
him it's crazy like he's a girl
to be josh leyva is is hard it's tiring
yeah that's a tough job so many dicks
and [ __ ] and genitals always being
thrown at you
god poor guy he can't catch them all
what is he gonna do
i don't know just take more sexy
pictures that's all he can do i mean
he's feeding them that's why
he's feeding the wolves had an only fans
he'd buy me a house that's a
does it we've talked about it but he's
really he doesn't want it he's morals
he doesn't want to yeah he has morals
stupid ass [ __ ] good guy he's a
classy man
yeah he doesn't play that case i guess
to answer your question um i think
like all we would all want to say no
right like of course there is no bias we
are looking at the credentials we are
looking if
right but i think we've just been
conditioned at least in the us we've
been conditioned
even as early as like watching [ __ ]
like disney movies you know like the
villain is always the ugly
darker one like it's they're more frail
in the media i like it
for sure the what the media media yeah
me
me personally i think i know it's like
it's hard to like people just attracted
to like things that are beautiful
but i think for me because i'm in comedy
and fitness those are my two main
like gauges if i like someone one if
they have a sense of humor and then one
if they're a [ __ ] or not
so if they're someone's not down like if
i like let's say we go like go hiking
and like yeah and they're like i don't
want to step in the creek my [ __ ] she
was gonna get wet i'm like oh i can't
connect with this i don't care how fine
this is
that's me
i feel like how hot they are
only affects me for about five to ten
seconds yeah
and as soon as they become a human being
i'm already judging them yeah i have two
other gauges you have two other gauges
that are way more important
that matter more to me yeah sometimes i
can't even help it though like if it's
if it's like someone that's just
attractive and then for me personally i
end up
feeling weird i don't know like horny
not
something happens i don't know what it
is no not horny like in a way where i'm
like
i end up feeling like more
self-conscious or like i don't feel
worthy or something i don't know what
happened to a good looking person
like i get really nervous really weird
like i can't talk right like i don't
know what the [ __ ] happens like that's
why we never have
conversations yeah that's why our
relationship you know
just too hot what if the super hot
person was next to you
and you just say like some normal [ __ ]
like oh i like caesar salad
do you still go like i can't control
myself around this person or you're like
damn this was a [ __ ]
bimbo i'm sure because that feeling that
feeling that i'm talking about right now
i haven't felt that
since like [ __ ] early 20s like
that's something that happens to me all
the time it's just that if it does
happen you're just like damn
i felt that before i've had friends that
are like really good looking
right and like we're you know we're cool
or whatever and then
like i go to there i go to their house
and they're [ __ ] slobs and it's just
like
it like damages my image of them like
outside he's like oh he's fly he's cool
but he [ __ ] lit
he sleeps on a dirty mattress with no
uh sheets or box or legs and i'm like
it's just mattress
like a homeless man and a crack house
yeah it's just like it's just like
damn bro yeah like yeah
like i couldn't they focused so much on
this that they forgot about this
yeah yeah that's crazy you know i don't
know maybe that's why they try so hard
yeah yeah to make up for it huh
yeah their messy lifestyle yeah because
they've get they've been given
everything because they're good looking
true yeah so generally attractive people
are perceived as more intelligent
more socially skilled more appealing
personalities more moral more
altruistic succeed uh way more are
hirable by managers and just more
competent
people in general and that's just the
general i always think they're lazy as
[ __ ] i agree i agree with the with
getting hired because a lot of times
like for
certain job titles or companies a lot of
times they want to hire a cute
receptionist
right like brings in clients or for
whatever reason like the receptionist of
the company the reception
the receptionist is always good looking
or
you know most of the time most of the
time sometimes they look like [ __ ]
normal people you know what i mean but a
lot of times they're like
[ __ ] instagram models or something
you know what i mean it's just like that
you know
even hosts or hostesses of like nice
restaurants are like that like the dude
or the chick looks like a model
hell yeah you want to be greeted by
something that looks nice
and then you want to ugly ass gremlin in
the back cooking something you know
would you like a clam chowder i don't
want that
i don't want that compliments to the
chef and then it's like
can you tell the chef thank you and he
goes son i heard that you liked
the dish and then it's like oh i lost my
appetite what the [ __ ]
you made this you made this
[Applause]
i put all my energy into my food
that's what i think i got i got so many
weird stereotypes when i see an ugly
person i'm like
you probably go with money because you
got to compensate for something
yup yup you have to pay extra for dinner
on a date
yeah if you're if you're if you're super
smart probably ugly probably ugly
see me coming up like how i got a
like attractive chicks was through my
humor
i remember i i i dated one of the
cheerleaders in high school that was
like
everybody thought she was bad and when i
was a junior she was a senior
oh damn yeah we got together and i
remember some i was like how the [ __ ]
did you i'm like [ __ ] i don't know dude
i mean i am an all-star running back
that's
a nerd or like a band geek and then
you're just like i'm just funny
but he's like no i was a [ __ ] athlete
bro i was like
i could have gone pro i mean let's be
real
that's so [ __ ] good who can fact
check who can fact check right now i'll
be real let's get real
that's not a [ __ ] nobody that's not a
glory story dude you gotta [ __ ]
you gotta be like one of those nerds are
like man i was a [ __ ]
i was a clarinet guy and i [ __ ] a
cheerleader no but check it out but
check it out i had like
busted teeth i was short you know what i
mean like so it's like but you're still
off
job though but still though bro like i
hate it i would talk like this in high
school
oh really because i hated showing my
teeth i i learned i mean it's not stupid
it sounds stupid now like a turtle yeah
exactly i'll be able to talk like this
and not show my teeth because my teeth
are so [ __ ] up
so for me to laugh with a girl at her
like me
how do you laugh i laugh like this
[Laughter]
that's good like robert de niro oh yeah
i'm gonna think he has [ __ ] up teeth
no no no i used to i used to
but is it hot like depending on
so many other things yeah oh yeah cause
there'll be girls out there that all
these guys are just
thirsting over there and i'm like her
yeah
yeah true yeah everyone i'm everyone has
their preferences yeah
that's true yeah especially now yeah
especially now
absolutely judge judging for someone
absolutely but yeah so this article
talks about attractiveness
in the uh courtroom and that
uh well attractiveness doesn't really
affect
whether a judge would dictate uh
someone's guilty or not
that has no effect on that but the
amount of sentencing the amount of years
someone does
they should be punished for their ugly
uh attracting
crazy huge huge impact there's a
correlation of
the ugly you are the more time you do
they're like we
okay it's a it's a crime not only that
you burglarize
but you're ugly and society shouldn't
[ __ ] have to look at that visual
pollution
solitary solitary confinement
no eyeballs on you you're gonna walk
into the courtroom the [ __ ] the cops
that are in the room they're gonna look
at you like
oh you're gonna you're gonna be you're
gonna go inside you're going for a while
but sir i only stole
a [ __ ] bubble gums but you're ugly
son
you're ugly and the judge is salty as
[ __ ] and it's like oh you're way too
good-looking yeah
yeah i was never you and i got picked on
by kids that look like you so you're
getting 30 years
now i feel like that's that's a thing
yeah i'm sure like that there's
too many fine guys in in jail huh um
well that's all i think that's better
for me though so like keep it keep them
in there
yeah yeah so uh on average attractive
like and this is like through studies
like they had like uh
college students come in to kind of rate
the attractiveness
of certain criminals uh on scale of one
through five
and so the attractiveness about
criminals
yeah uh the attractive criminals
uh for their sentencing got an average
of like about two years
in jail whereas the unattractive
criminals in this pool
got four years with the same crime
though
yeah yeah they used same crimes because
that'd be okay yeah yeah cause what if
it was just the uglier people did worse
crimes
that's true this this does talk about it
too they're asking the articles asking
like whether or not unattractive people
might be more likely to commit crimes
because of their unattractiveness
and that attracted people don't
necessarily need to do crime because
they have other avenues right
that's the privilege i feel like that
goes back to the whole we're talking
about
i don't know if we're on camera or off
camera but we're talking about like uh
uh like santa claus being white and and
the easter bunny being white
i wonder if that people say like oh but
if he was black or brown he would have
got this much time
but because he's white the race thing so
i feel like that's like
the same the same thing like if you're
ugly and if you're if you're ugly
you're a person of color if you're
attractive you're white it's like kind
of like the same
yeah not doesn't go together but like
it's like the same kind of like
comparison
in their own maybe they're talking about
like universal ugly
like not just like you know like some
people have preference right like they
might look at a a girl
like that's a low rider model and be
like oh but then some other people be
like man she's fine as [ __ ] what are you
talking about
that's my kind of girl yeah but that's
that's like preference right but there's
universal ugly like no matter what race
you are if your eye is on this side and
then you're ugly what the [ __ ]
happened to you you know you don't no
matter what race you are
yeah yeah yeah if you're gonna hate you
guys and stuff
i once went sorry i said i'll make it i
once went out for an audition
for this uh movie or show or whatever uh
and the the description
said male mid 20s
ugly short fat that i went out for that
this my agent submitted me
[ __ ] you afraid
it's brutal but you know what the good
thing is i didn't get it and i didn't
get it
that's the first time that's the first
time i said i didn't get it i'm too good
looking for that right but did you try
for the roll
i did i really did what if it was
because you weren't fat enough
i think it was because i wasn't ugly
enough or what if it paid millions
though wouldn't you want that rule
yeah yeah that's true and then i worked
my hardest to get in shape so when it
comes out i'm [ __ ] ripped
you know so i was like i got fat for
that like jonah yeah
yeah i got fat for that roll even though
i was just
yes and to close out this video another
aspect to this uh
to this article and and study is that
defendants are
criminals with more like baby faces and
like and babyface is defined
by like a slightly rounder faces less
angular
wider eyes and like just kind of having
more of like this innocent look yeah
they actually get less of a sentence as
well i'm good
i'm good let's go rob a store right it's
ugly
fine and then babyface babyface gets the
most
uh well they didn't compare the babyface
with the attractive people it's like a
separate study but it was kind of like
in line with the fact that
the justice system does there's a lot of
bias
in attractiveness and how you look and
appear in court yeah
and so if you're unattractive you're
kind of [ __ ] out of luck if you're a
criminal
yeah hello guys thank you guys so much
for watching all of our videos and i
know it's been a million years in the
making but we finally got
just kidding news merch yep so make sure
you go down to the store below
and you can round round yeah you can get
a piece
of jk news and thank you guys for
supporting thank you
bye-bye
[Music]
you